[Music]
you're gonna move
I haven't decided
see that's what I'm worried about
the fury I knew is always three steps
ahead
I remember correctly
you called me
pontelos's request
your lack of contact over the past few
years sent a pretty clear message
meaning
you're not ready for this Fury
there's a very real threat out there
you were never the same after the blip
you always told me there is no shame in
Walking Away
when the steps are uncertain
so check your footing
otherwise someone's gonna get hurt
[Music]
Since You've Been Gone
things have gotten much worse
how do you think I came back
[Music]
you're in no shape for this fight that
lies before us
good friend
this is personal
very few of us know about the wars
fought in the shadows that have raged on
this planet
[Music]
do you feel responsible
where are the Avengers
this war is one I have to fight alone
you're the most wanted man on the planet
you don't know what they have planned
for you
the Great Neck Fury
one last fight
[Music]